[Musica]
[Applauso]
se vi do alle spalle sono cosciente di
non potervi vedere se mi giro e vi
guardo così vedo qualcosa e dentro di me
posso pensare che in fondo è tutto ciò
che posso vedere ma è solo quando levo
l'altra mano che capisco che in realtà
potevo vedere molto di più questo è
quello che è successo possiamo dire così
alla medicina che per secoli ha guardato
al corpo dell'essere umano pensando di
vedere la totalità di quello che poteva
vedere in realtà ne vedeva solo una
parte le cose non sono poi andate così
male direte Perché in fondo alla
medicina ha fatto passi da gigante ha
studiato il corpo dell'essere umano
ha trovato In molti casi le cause di
molte malattie in alcuni casi
altrettanto tanti ha trovato anche delle
terapie quindi delle soluzioni prova ne
è il fatto che l'aspettativa di vita
soprattutto nel nostro mondo nel mondo
occidentale
comunque molto aumentata negli ultimi
decenni Ma negli anni 80 del secolo
scorso un gruppo di cardiologhe
americane incominciò a domandarsi una
cosa e cioè non è che per caso la
medicina fino a quel momento avesse
guardato al corpo umano così Con metà
visuale non è che in realtà fossimo
stati fino a quel momento ciechi di
fronte al corpo delle donne perché delle
cardiologhe perché era proprio nel campo
della cardiologia che incominciavano ad
accumularsi dei dati delle evidenze che
dimostravano che in realtà le donne
rispondevano in maniera differente alle
terapie arrivavano al pronto soccorso in
condizioni peggiori rispetto agli uomini
quando avevano un infarto e anche la
chirurgia In fondo non funzionava così
tanto bene È proprio per rispondere a
quelle domande per darsi un Perché Che è
nata la medicina di genere ed è di
questo di cui voglio parlare stasera
non sono un medico sono una giornalista
mi occupo di comunicazione della scienza
in particolare di comunicazione della
medicina Ed è proprio facendo il mio
lavoro che a un certo punto ho
conosciuto la medicina di genere e Mi
sono appassionata tanto da scriverne un
libro
Ecco perché mi sono appassionata alla
medicina di genere sicuramente per una
questione di equità di giustizia Se
volete anche di completezza di un
discorso Ma poi perché penso che parlare
guardare alla medicina di genere è un
buon modo per capire che la medicina è
un costrutto sociale che affonda le sue
radici nella società in cui viene agita
e sviluppata e questo noi lo possiamo
vedere se mettiamo a confronto la
medicina occidentale con quello
orientale capiamo subito le differenze
senza giudicare cosa è meglio e cose
peggio sono culture diverse che hanno
sviluppato un modo di guardare alla
malattia diverso
Ecco quindi è proprio questa differenza
e il fatto che la scienza in qualche
modo la scienza medica affondi le sue
radici nella società che mi ha molto
affascinato perché è un modo per pensare
alla scienza come alla medicina come una
scienza medica quindi una scienza che
produce un rigore e
va avanti sui dati e sulle evidenze ma
allo stesso tempo è un prodotto
culturale
abbiamo detto è una scienza quindi
segue un metodo scientifico vuol dire
dati evidenze studi e qui casca l'asino
Perché sulle donne non abbiamo molti
dati di cui parlare almeno fino agli
anni 90 del secolo scorso sempre quando
proprio grazie a queste donne
cardiologhe in realtà fu posto questo
problema tanto che l'FBI che è
l'autorità regolatoria dei medici delle
medicine in America decise di mettere in
qualche modo una regola di avere una
misura minima di donne negli studi
scientifici
vi spiego questo concetto Forse con
altre parole più semplici la stragrande
maggioranza delle medicine che prendiamo
noi oggi non sono state testate sui
corpi delle donne
Beh direte funzionano Quindi tutto
sommato perché dobbiamo metterci a
studiarli anche sui corpi delle donne
Beh perché se vogliamo andare a guardare
le differenze le differenze le troviamo
sono tante e fanno la differenza
Ma perché i ricercatori non si sono
appassionati al corpo delle donne perché
non hanno coinvolto le donne negli studi
scientifici Certo non è un caso di
accanimento particolare ma semplicemente
di nuovo ci parla del fatto che se ad
agire la medicina a costruire la
medicina Sono principalmente gli uomini
e se la cultura in fondo ci dice che a
parte per facendo eccezione per il
sistema ovviamente riproduttivo il corpo
della donna in realtà è una versione in
miniatura del corpo dell'uomo in fondo
non abbiamo bisogno di andarlo a
studiare in particolare e poi ovviamente
c'è il problema del modello la scienza
adora i modelli perché sono semplici in
qualche modo semplificano e amplificano
quello che noi vogliamo andare a
dimostrare o a ricercare perché non c'è
un rumore di fondo perché non ci sono
dei fattori confondenti e il corpo della
donna è un corpo complesso che ha molti
fattori confondenti il primo il
più grande è sicuramente la fluttuazione
ormonale mensile e poi c'è un problema
etico le donne possono rimanere incinta
e siccome noi dei farmaci prima
dell'efficacia andiamo a vedere la
sicurezza Nessuno ci può dire che quel
particolare molecola che è quella
sostanza che stiamo sperimentando poi
non possa essere nociva per il nascituro
Insomma tutta una serie di ragioni per
cui in fondo era più semplice fare a
meno del corpo delle donne questo come
dire abbiamo detto fino a gli anni 90
del 1900 poi le cose sono cambiate e
adesso Tutto sommato non esiste al di là
delle leggi o del diciamo di come gli
enti regolatori decidono di ehm in
qualche modo finanziare la ricerca non
esiste nessun ricercatore che
sperimenterebbe un farmaco su un
campione omogeneo per del genere e anche
per etnia Quindi tutto sommato questo ci
mette al riparo da qui in avanti
sulla sicurezza e sull'efficacia dei
farmaci ma cosa fare con i farmaci che
sono stati sviluppati fino adesso non
possiamo mica rincominciare tutto quanto
da capo Ecco quello che possiamo fare è
guardare con uno sguardo di genere ai
dati che ci vengono dall'uso che noi
facciamo di questi farmaci
un caso scuola Se volete è quello di un
farmaco che si usa per l'insonnia Questo
è uno dei pochi farmaci per cui sempre
la famosa fda di prima Ha deciso che sul
Bugiardino sul foglietto illustrativo
andasse scritto che le donne avevano
bisogno di un dosaggio diverso e questo
perché Perché
i ricercatori si sono resi conto che
nelle donne che prendevano questo
farmaco era più probabile che
accadessero degli incidenti
automobilistici la mattina come se
questo farmaco avesse un'azione più
prolungata nel corpo delle donne
piuttosto che nel corpo degli uomini
perché la scienza decida che
effettivamente il dosaggio debba essere
cambiato Ci vogliono però delle prove
delle prove costruite ad hoc ed è quello
che hanno fatto alcuni gruppi di ricerca
in tutto il mondo all'inizio degli anni
2000 hanno costruito degli Studi per
dimostrare proprio questo che questo
farmaco nel corpo delle donne aveva
un'azione prolungata ed era Quindi
questa la causa del fatto che ci fossero
maggiori incidenti stradali
come mai nel corpo delle donne i farmaci
possono avere un'azione più lunga
possono rimanere in circolo più a lungo
che nel corpo dell'uomo questo ha a che
fare con il modo con cui noi
metabolizziamo se volete digeriamo un
farmaco e questo ha a che fare con molti
fattori fattori come la percentuale di
grasso corporeo che nelle donne Ahimè è
maggiore il tempo di svuotamento
gastrico di transito intestinale e
ovviamente ancora una volta gli ormoni
molti fattori abbiamo detto perché la
donna è un organismo complesso che però
fanno la differenza guardare a queste
differenze Allora ci potrebbe far
sorgere anche un'altra curiosità di
andare a vedere altri grandi gruppi di
popolazioni su cui le sperimentazioni
non si possono fare per esempio i
bambini cosa succede nei bambini o non
si fanno come gli anziani quando noi
sappiamo che la popolazione mondiale sta
invecchiando sempre più e quindi
veri fruitori della gran parte dei
nostri farmaci sono gli anziani ma
torniamo alle cardiologhe da cui eravamo
partite e alle loro domande circa per
esempio l'infarto Perché le donne che
arrivano al pronto soccorso con un
infarto stanno in media Peggio degli
uomini questo a che fare con il modo con
cui noi conosciamo i sintomi
dell'infarto che nel nostro immaginario
ovviamente sono legati a un pressione al
petto a un dolore al braccio sinistro
nelle donne non è così nelle donne
l'infarto si presenta ovviamente stiamo
parlando della media in maniera diversa
con un bruciore allo stomaco con un
dolore che si può irradiare fino alla
schiena con delle sudorazioni tanto che
spesso sono scambiati per sintomi
gastrici le donne non lo riconoscono per
prima e a volte non lo riconoscono
neanche i medici e quindi arrivano in
ospedale in ritardo e anche quando per
esempio si devono sottoporre ha una
chirurgia per esempio le chirurgie che
aiutano a allargare le arterie che
magari si sono occluse in realtà le
cardiologhe americane dicevano perché le
donne rispondono peggio a questa
chirurgia Perché i device piccolissimi
che si mettono dentro le arterie per
riaprirle erano state disegnate sulle
arterie degli uomini che in media sono
più grandi quindi una volta inserite
nelle arterie delle donne molto spesso
davano de sanguinamenti e la chirurgia
non riusciva
sono passati 40 anni Mi direte a questo
punto di prove ne abbiamo accumulate le
cose sono cambiate in realtà non molto
e a dire la verità non è che come vi ho
detto prima c'è da rifare tutto c'è però
da guardare alla medicina con uno
sguardo diverso con uno sguardo delle
differenze in primis Se volete quella
fra uomini e donne Ma poi anche le altre
e guardate che guardare con lo sguardo
delle differenze aiuta anche gli uomini
perché ci sono patologie che colpiscono
gli uomini di cui si parla pochissimo Si
parla solo al femminile come il tumore
al seno o l'osteoporosi le cose sono
cambiate un pochettino da quando io ho
iniziato comunque ad occuparmene e in
Italia oggi viene insegnata la medicina
di genere in alcune università ci sono
dei master di formazione per i medici e
soprattutto abbiamo una legge una legge
che quasi nessuno conosce A dire il vero
anche perché è stata Mmm votata subito
prima della pandemia e abbiamo avuto
altro a cui pensare in questi ultimi due
anni ma questa legge impone in qualche
modo alle regioni di istituire degli
osservatori per la medicina di genere di
raccogliere i dati in maniera differente
fra uomini e donne di istituire dei
percorsi di prevenzione e cura che siano
genderet oriented che siano orientati al
genere
cambiare prospettiva cambiare sguardo
guardare le differenze
vedere ciò che prima si pensava non
esistesse sicuramente un esercizio
faticoso ma spero dopo stasera che anche
voi insieme a me capitate capirete che è
necessario Grazie
[Applauso]